hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to surgeon simulator for the
iPad now technically I didn't own an
iPad so I had to go get an iPad and then
figure out how to record an iPad so that
I could play this game for you guys and
because I am a glutton for punishment
and if you didn't know I played this
game before I'm gonna do it again all
over again with the brand-new lovely
controls of touch so frabjous day glue
cool eh let's get to it now I tried its
little training mode and I tried a
little bit of the actual surgery and let
me just tell you it's delightful and I
love it now as always I have my lovely
nurse here to help me well you don't see
a nurse over here well maybe that's your
problem stead of mine and I am gonna do
this delightfully now I'm gonna take my
time and I'm actually gonna be very
careful about what I do as I what I'm
not gonna be careful with Bob here who
is the son of a [ __ ] and not my best
friend Bob by the way this son of a
[ __ ] is sorted that boarded me at every
turn as I try to help and you've stuck
my hammer and already good for you now
the many problems I have with this game
is that the controls are made to be
intentionally bad is that you can see
here as I'm trying to this is much
easier in the little tiny version that
you did in the training as I'm wailing
on his ribs here you can see that he's
slowly dying on me this son of a [ __ ]
does not why isn't this working this
should work shouldn't it I'm really
giving these good Wallops here but no no
you're gonna be a little bit of a dick
ain't you Bob thank you Bob
you're gonna bleed a little bit of an
[ __ ] as I try to save your life well
I mean not right now this obviously
isn't trying to save his life right here
everyone just focus on me for a few
seconds as I just caress Bob with my
love hammer if you know what I mean not
gonna oh no Bob died all right fine
whatever I just had to do that because
me and Bob we have a history over here
not my friend Bob this is dick Bob
everyone say hi had a Richard Bob would
that go get back here you son of a [ __ ]
it's like he oh this is not going any
bit better you get out of that rib you
son of a [ __ ]
you're an axe not Oh Oh what happened
why is everything flashing red
he's probably dying he's all alone blood
what's going on here always flatlining
oh oh wait a minute I know I do I know
what I'm doing
maybe they didn't train me this in
Nicaraguan school I had to do it through
trial and ever I had to go through a lot
of bobs before I was able to figure out
I'm supposed to different real item
there's this new stuff over here I was
exploring a bit so I wouldn't be totally
foreign to this now I don't know how to
use that but I think it has to do with
that button right there right there see
oh no on there no okay there we go ah
see okay so those are ready for whatever
the hell he decides to die on me again
whoo-hoo all right let's get bagging is
go there you son of a [ __ ] Thor is a
question to ask you what's the opposite
of Thor okay that's good yeah really
massage those lungs with this axe
I'm sure that's delightful as to what he
wants to do what you aim where I'm
tapping you son of a how about you get
out of the ribs for the okay never mind
you're just gonna keep doing that ain't
ya
you're adorable and by oh that's good to
know
oh he's dying baby be clear no clear
clear clear okay nope damn it I was
pooping it as hard as I could Boop it
didn't Boop the son of a [ __ ] just
dumped him died on me I put one on his
face
I put one on his ass did it work I think
it worked
holy hell I don't I didn't I actually
didn't need to press a button I just
needed how to both of them on him well I
used up my one try so I hope he doesn't
die again let's try something else now
this one how do I turn it on hello okay
how's it going it's not going wow I'm
touching it somehow the saw is now in
the ribs and I don't know what I need to
do that's my best bet the saw is
actually the best for this particular
scenario because I just gotta get it for
okay it seems like everything wants to
go inside the ribs almost as if they
messed the physics system up even more
than they did before I know what I'm
doing it kind of always died again
well that's just too bad I didn't even
get a chance he just up and died on me
just sort of a [ __ ] why is this harder
why is it harder you think it'd be
easier cuz I don't even need to control
with a wer and stuff okay whatever I'm
assuming that this button on the side
actually need to there we go
okay now that that's got let me bring
that slowly and just gently caress the
ribs oh so nice so tender and mild oh
just like that like a dream like a
dreamboat like dreamboat Willy Steamboat
Willie can you actually put the ribs
okay
wrong rib I'm a Jackson go where I'm
aiming that would be delightful no no no
no no no no no no no no no no that is a
lot of blood okay that's a lot of blood
okay I got it Bob you don't worry your
life is in my hands my hands are dirty
with the blood of millions I don't think
you have anything to worry about okay
maybe you have something to worry about
oh no no I really am trying to be
careful here good now the ribs gone and
he's bleeding rapidly let's hope that I
can get this injected into his butt
soon enough to stop him from dying and
we're good
oh we're so good look he's bleeding out
of his face a little bit but that's
besides the point
let's just get all this useless junk out
of here oh I'm such a tool to give toy I
need this to cut that come on be gentle
with it be gentle with it
okie dokie you were that gentle with it
because I see the spouting gouts of
blood okay okay
I'm not gonna make it am I did I get it
nope that's gonna be doctors how you
doing out there cuz I'm doing just great
with this game god I love it I love I
love doing this is my favorite everyone
knows that this game is just my favorite
this is now where I've tapped why you
just be normal
oh god he's okay come on clutter eat
free Bob I can't believe I did it oh my
god that's amazing oh that is not the
hit where's the hammer go I'll just pull
it out whatever things don't care about
the ribs anyway
apparently oh let's stop him from
bleeding or something
about feeling good Bob feeling good good
I'm feeling good about this
if you're feeling good I'm feeling
double extra douche okay things are
looking on the up-and-up got a lot of
blood left I think I'm actually getting
the hang of it good job doctor shut up
nurse I know when I need compliments
which is now please compliment me on my
amazing doctoring skills all those
failed attempts at killing people I mean
saving people actually paid off now if I
could just get them got hey we did it
not bad
cut that I think I got it cut that one
that oh okay you're gonna you're gonna
actually okay all right Bugatti he's
still bleeding okay come on I'm too
close don't fail this one on me now oh
don't feel it now save him okay dead
heart I didn't get I didn't cut one of
them oh you got to be joking me okay so
I need to be very ah very so precise
about this Oh goddamn it
Oh goddamn it I didn't do that
okay okay boss no more time Bob was a
drunkard you useless anyway I guess if
he was drunk could be very useful now
right now
Bobby's get done yeah
got it Breck got it bak kut come on okay
now just gently I did I did it good job
doctor you so handsome thank you nurse
I know so good game yeah God that was
brutal
oh god it's taking it took a while to
get used to what the touch controls
wanted from me but what's that guy used
to it I was able to do the easiest
surgery oh I can't wait for the future
there's more surgeries after that
there's more surprises there's there's
things other than just regular surgery
on this son [ __ ] so you want to see
them right in the comments below write
me words of encouragement - and other
stuff to that effect so anyway thank you
all so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this one this was kind of fun
kinda click the annotations and check
out my playlist of my old surgeon
simulator stuff there's a lot more stuff
in there I got way angrier than that one
than this one so thanks again as always
I will see you in the next video
through that all the other tools are
being like giant [ __ ]